welcome back y'all we are here with Eva
Longoria Give It Up
so Eva's new movie is called Flamin Hot
it's the story about the creation of a
certain flavor of a certain tasty chip
snack and to celebrate the movie we've
got a new game dedicated to all things
hot it's called hot enough for you
that's my bedroom yeah let's get a hose
down here Lord what do you say will you
help us out
yes
well hey Kelly I am here sorry about
that you you caught me in the middle of
practicing pickleball
it is that's a really hard game that's a
really hard game how you doing Kelly how
you doing dama Longoria
that's right thank you nice to see you
your highness okay that's enough of that
listen up we got a game here and today
the answer to each clue I'll give you is
something hot could be hot tamales could
be hot dates could be a hot Supreme
Being you get the idea you know what I'm
talking about but what you're going to
do now is you're going to hit your
button and answer if you know if you're
right
you gonna hear that but if you're wrong
the other person can steal that's what
you're gonna get that's right well let's
see what happens ladies okay now Eva you
playing for your side of the audience
and Kelly is playing for her side there
you go make some noise
surprise well there is a prize there's a
pretty hot prize on the line too see
what I did there see what I did there
okay here is your first question okay
if you're looking to sweat while doing a
little downward facing dog oh
Hot Yoga it's hot yoga
you got it downward dogs
that's right we all been there doing
that downward dog I'm more of a uh more
of a mountain pose guy myself but mostly
because I made them okay here's the next
one oh my God these colorful aircrafts
conveniently okay go ahead hot air
balloons it is hot air balloons
unbelievable
[Applause]
that's right what
that's right hot air balloons also
something you might see while you're
doing yoga okay here's your next uh
here's your next one
I'll give you a minute okay if you are
the rapper Nelly you enjoy encouraging
people Kelly it's getting hot in here so
take off all your cotton here what's up
what's up
what's that one I'm getting excited
about my wife okay let's uh let's move
on here's your next question back in the
early days of the World Wide Web you had
your earthlinks and prodigies Hotmail
Hotmail
that's right no idea I'm back oh we got
ourselves a tie here I shouldn't have
known that I knew I'm that old I think I
had a Hotmail I'm 40. yeah yeah I'm
40-ish I think I yeah
I still have a hot male it's uh love it
when you call me Big Papa 37 at Hotmail
so uh
okay here's your next question
now it's the 90s and we're heading to
the mall you want to go there and drink
some orange julius maybe go to a Hot
Topic go to a Hot Topic that's right
what I feel powerful it was amazing I
never would have gotten that and I
shocked to feel powerful
that was good Kelly now in the lead now
in the lead Hot Topic that's where I get
my oh my God so I get my guy liner okay
here's your next question these little
pools are basically Nature's jacuzzis oh
it's so sad hot tubs
[Applause]
all right
it is hot springs I'm sorry Kelly
you see what happens
in nature of nature
got me there there you go it always does
I enjoyed watching that you got cocky
girl yeah I know I did I'm calming down
okay we still got a tie here here's your
next question okay this oxymoronically
named ointment is something you might
Icy Hot oh it's icy hot you got it
we're even looking for
a call in that very serious public
domain music means it's time for our
last question okay this one is worth
Five Points what yeah interesting
interesting here we go oh mother this
delicious dessert comes with nuts or
without Kelly a hot fudge sundae it's a
hot fudge sundae
okay
of course everyone is a winner on the
Kelly Clarkson show y'all so you are all
going to get to heat things up with the
Anova Precision cooker the Anova
sous-vide kit used by Professionals for
decades works by circulating heated
water in a pot cooking food to the exact
set temperature for perfect results
every time you're welcome
[Applause]
[Music]